this video is brought to you by onshape
try the professional plan for free for
up to 6 months with the link in the
description after spending 7 Days in
orbit around the Earth the space shuttle
Orbiter now has arguably the most
difficult portion of its mission to
complete a hell blazing Journey Through
the Earth's upper atmosphere where it
will travel so fast that it will Rip air
molecules apart forming a layer of
superheated plasma around the aircraft
re-entry is where the space shuttle
truly became a one-of-a-kind spacecraft
the space shuttle was a radical new idea
a spacecraft capable of not only
surviving the immense heat of re-entry
but capable of transitioning to
aerodynamic flight which required
careful molding of its wings and tail
balancing the needs of an unpowered
glider with the needs of a re-entry
vehicle this is the insane engineering
of
re-entry the re-entry procedure begins
with a 2 to 4 minute burn of the orbital
maneuvering engines while the spacecraft
is upside down and traveling backwards
with an orbital speed of around 7 km per
second the ohms pods need to reduce the
Orbiter speed by just 0.1 km/s 1.3% of
its velocity to lower its orbit enough
to bring it into a collision course with
the Earth's upper atmosphere a precise
maneuver bleed to Little Speed and the
Orbiter will overshoot its narrow window
for Success skimming through the thin
upper atmosphere and potentially bounce
back into space the Orbiter has wings
that generate lift after all bleed too
much speed and the Orbiter will descend
through the atmosphere too fast reaching
the thick lower atmosphere before enough
speed has been leeched away resulting in
catastrophic overheating this narrow
entry window was called the entry flight
Corridor once the delicate retr firing
sequence has been completed the next
phase of re-entry Begins the reaction
controls system flips the shuttle around
and places it into a 40° upwards pitch
angle ready to meet the Earth's
atmosphere entering the upper atmosphere
at 30 times the speed of sound the speed
is so great it begins to rip air
molecules apart creating a glowing cloud
of charged plasma around the lower
surface of the Orbiter with Peak
temperatures reaching
1,650 de cus nothing like this had ever
been attempted a blunt body capsule like
every other re entry capsule to date
designed purely for thermal protection
is an engineering challenge but tack on
the needs of an aircraft and the task
gets vastly more difficult thankfully
NASA had a test run in 1959 with the X15
the fastest plane in the history of
humankind and it Advanced our
understanding of hypersonic flight
providing many lessons that were
incorporated into the space shuttle's
design however the X15 had one major
advantage over the space shuttle it this
didn't need to launch itself into orbit
it didn't even launch from the ground
instead launching from the belly of a
B52 this allowed the X15 to use a
state-of-the advanced heat resistant
Aerospace metal in canel X with a Max
operating temperature of 980 de C the
space shuttle could not use this metal
in Canal X is too heavy about 180%
heavier than an equivalent aluminium
airframe a massive issue for an aircraft
to designed to be carried to orbit the
space shuttle airframe therefore is not
made from inconel X it is composed of
lightweight aluminium which has a max
operating temperature of just
177° five times lower than Inc Canal X
the Orbiter would experience
temperatures 10 times greater than this
for extended periods of its re-entry
flight to make matters worse one of the
principal lessons learned during the X15
program was that the hot pain pink foam
a blade of coating sprayed onto the
plane for the top speed flights was
completely unusable for the space
shuttle and a blade of coating is a
sacrificial material designed to
gradually burn and fall away from the
aircraft pulling the heat with it
however the ablative coating of the X15
had a nasty habit of burning away from
the nose of the plane and begin
attaching itself to the cockpit Windows
rendering the pilots completely blind
which presented a bit of a problem at
one point the engineers of the X15
considered attaching small explosives to
the window and intentionally exploding
the outer pane of glass to remove the
ablade of stained window leaving only
the inner pain for landing thankfully
they came up with a much less risky
solution of installing a mechanical
eyelid to the left window that remained
closed until the high-speed portion of
the flight concluded providing the pilot
one clean window to land with an
extremely primitive solution that
created stability issues as the open
eyelid acted like a Canard causing the
plane to pitch up roll right and yaw
right even more terrifying this coating
became explosive when mixed with liquid
oxygen and could be triggered by even a
slight impact a massive safety concern
for a plane that required a liquid
oxygen oxidizer to operate a danger that
would be multiplied manyfold with a
vehicle filled with half a million lers
of liquid oxygen the ative was also not
reusable which would drastically
increase the cost of refurbishing the
shuttle between flights the space
shuttle would need to be better as the
space shuttle descended through the
atmosphere its nose and wings bore the
brunt of the re-entry heat the
highpressure shock waves forming around
them have created a layer of superheated
plasma if this heat managed to find its
way into the delicate aluminium
framework inside the Orbiter it would be
game over this is exactly what happened
to the Colombia shuttle as a result of
damage to the leading edge of These
Wings the first step in protecting the
Orbiter surface was to keep this
superheated plasma as far away from the
surface as possible the nose wings and
belly of the Orbiter was carefully
crafted to ensure shock waves were kept
at Bay we can see how using scharen
Imaging a pointed missil likee vehicle
pierces through the air with efficiency
and in doing so creates a shock wave
attached to its nose with an angle
determined by its mock number this shock
wave is simply a region of incredibly
high pressure and with that pressure
comes incredibly high temperatures this
can have disastrous effects as DARPA
experienced twice in 2010 and 2011 when
testing their sharp-nosed Hypersonic
re-entry vehicle the htv2 within 9
Minutes of re-entering Earth's
atmosphere both vehicles disintegrated
as a result of the 1,900 de heat
penetrating their metallic skin the htv2
completed its mission of collect cting
Hypersonic flight data but the space
shuttle needed to not only survive this
mode of flight but to do it repeatedly
with minimal refurbishment a good
portion of this heat could be kept away
from the aircraft skin with blunt body
design which creates a rounded bow
Shockwave with a layer of insulating
lower pressure air between the vehicle
and the shock wave reducing heat
transfer for this reason the space
shuttle surface is carefully molded to
take advantage of this phenomenon the
rounded nose cross-section gradually
transitions to a blunted triangle this
shape minimized the heat reaching the
less protected sidewall of the shuttle
which used lower temperature insulation
we are now 7 minutes into the re-entry
procedure having descended 50 km in
altitude but only shedding 0.5 km/s over
velocity we've entered the period of
Maximum re-entry heat a Confluence of
speed and Atmospheric density the layer
of superheated plasma surrounding the
shutle is blocking communication to the
computers and astronauts inside a result
of free electrons in the plasma
interfering with electromagnetic
communication techniques a problem that
would last for the next 12 minutes for
now the shuttle is operating on its own
Telemetry data ensuring that 40° angle
of attack is maintained managing that
angle with a velocity of 6.5 km per
second was no easy task a massive
control surface was needed the elevant
on the outer wing would not suffice this
is where the rear body flap came into
play it was a massive control surface
underneath the shuttle's main engines
covered in high temperature insulation
the body flap doubled as a heat shield
for the shuttle's main engines with no
cooling liquid hydrogen running through
the nozzles the flap was needed to
Shield the engines from the heat of
re-entry on the space shuttle's third
flight the Kyper Airborne Observatory
flew underneath the Orbiter as it
re-entered and captured an infr red
image of its searing hot belly an
experimental program to validate NASA's
newly developed computational
calculations and experimental testing
this is what it saw the nose and leading
edges are a scorching 1, 1500° C far
beyond what the aluminium airframe
underneath is capable of enduring these
leading edges experiencing the hottest
temperatures needed the most heat
resistant material on the entire shuttle
a reinforced carbon carbon composite one
of the amazing materials created in the
Years between the development of the X15
and the space shuttle a carbon composite
manufactured with a special
postprocessing step it was initially
manufactured like any other carbon fiber
part a carbon fiber weave molded into
shape and bound together with a resin
however the heat of re-entry would set
the hydrocarbon resin on fire without
special treatment the post-processing
step would solve this problem the Caron
composite is placed in a vacuum chamber
and heated causing the hydrocarbon resin
to decompose releasing the hydrogens
leaving layers of pure carbon behind
graphite carbon fiber is bound together
by a maze of graphite strong and capable
of withstanding 1,
510° C they face head on Into The
Inferno of hypersonic flight the Leading
Edge of the Orbiter Wings is composed of
22 of these carbon carbon panels with
ceiling strips covering ing expansion
gaps between each panel an essential
solution to a lesson heard one during
the development of the X15 to
investigate the heat of hypersonic
flight the X15 was painted with a
special kind of paint that reacted to
heat and after one flight the X15
returned with strange wedge-shaped
patterns emanating from the Leading Edge
Expansion Joints small gaps in the
Leading Edge to allow the Inc canel skin
to bend and contort with the wing
without buckling this localized heating
was happening as a result of turbulent
flow increasing the rate of heat
transfer to the metallic skin of the
aircraft to fix this small floating
strips of Inc canel were placed over the
expansion gaps these strips of
reinforced carbon carbon serve the very
same purpose however there is one more
problem carabin is a thermally
conductive material not ideal for a heat
shield the space shuttle has been
traveling through the atmosphere for 15
minutes but is still traveling at 6 km/s
and contact has not been reestablished
through the cloud of plasma surrounding
the aircraft this is a sustained heat
and with carbon being conductive this
heat could make its way to the aluminium
airframe over this period of time if
these carbon carbon shields were
attached directly to the airframe the
heat would come in direct contact with
the metal raising it above its Max
operating temperature to prevent this
the panels were fitted with in Canal
attachment points that attached to the
aluminium airframe with Inc canel bolts
Inc canel being mostly made of steel is
a poor conductor of heat and could
handle the heat the carbon Parts
transferred to it without easily
transferring that heat to the aluminium
this wasn't enough to protect the
interior of the shuttle however a layer
of insulating tiles were placed
underneath the carbon carbon Shield too
the same insulation that was used on the
underside of the entire Orbiter the
space shuttle Columbia had 32,000 of
these tiles in two flavors low
temperature and high temperature white
and black but both of these tiles were
made from the same base material silica
fibers just a few millimet thick which
by volume made up just 10% of the tile
the remaining 90% was nothing but air an
excellent insulating material a thick
and light tile composed of a material
with a high operating temperature the
coating is where the tiles differ the
black tiles in St installed on the lower
portion of the shuttle were covered in a
black boros silicate and tetraboron
silic glass coating this black coating
helps dissipate heat before it can
conduct to the vulnerable inner
structure black for the same reason the
SR71 is black Kirk off's rule of
radiation this rule tells us a good
infrared heat absorber basically
anything black is also an equally
effective heat emitter with the heat
gained from Hypersonic flight vastly
higher than the heat gained from solar
radi radiation it's preferable to
prioritize outward heat radiation than
minimizing heat gained from solar
radiation so why isn't the entire space
shuttle black like the
SR71 the space shuttle has one important
difference with the SR71 it exited
Earth's atmosphere once outside the
Earth's atmosphere the intensity of
solar radiation increases drastically
with the longest Orbiter Mission at 17
days this heat had plenty of time to
conduct through to the p people inside
the Orbiter did have huge radiator
panels to reject heat to space but to
minimize their size we want to reflect
as much of that heat back into space and
for that reason they are white these
tiles were coated with a similar glass
coating but with an aluminium oxide
additive to provide the white coloring
the Coatings also helped to waterproof
and strengthen these porous tiles the
tiles were assembled like a giant
precisely engineered puzzle with 32,000
pieces each tile assigned a serial
number that corresponded to their
location shape and thickness the tiles
were created by mixing cotton-like
silica fibers with water this mixture
was then cast into large blocks and were
then dried in a microwave oven once
dried they could be cut into smaller
sheets the tiles varied from 25 mm to
127 mm thick with the 127 mm tiles
insulating up to
1,280 de Celsius these sheets were then
cut into their precise shapes according
to their assigned serial numbers using a
computer controlled milling machine we
are now coming through to the end of the
communication blackout and enough of the
heat of re-entry has reached the
aluminium airframe to cause it to expand
a major problem as these tiles are not
flexible in the slightest and are quite
Fragile the expanding airframe could
easily break the tiles and open up a
path for the superheated gas to
penetrate inside
the engineers needed a way to allow the
structure to move beneath the tiles
without causing the tiles to pop off to
do this the tiles were first glued in
groups to a layer of flexible nomax felt
this nomax fabric allowed the structure
beneath to flex expanding the Lower Side
of the felt without transferring that
strain to the upper layer attached to
the tiles these tiles and felt were then
attached to the shuttle using the same
adhesive a commercially available high
temperature RTV adhesive a bright red
silicone based adhesive to prevent
collisions between tiles gaps between
0.46 mm and 1.9 mm were included
thankfully the issue of turbulent flow
created by expansion gaps primarily
affected the leading edges of the wing
so these gaps were not covered on the
exterior of the shuttle in areas exposed
to lesser temperatures flexible heat
shields were used constructed from high
temperature silica and nox fibers to
create a flexible fabric which were sewn
together with the same fibers giving a
quilted blanket appearance with the NX
fabric capable of resisting temperatures
up to
370° and the silica fabric capable of
tolerating temperatures up to
650° these were lighter and easier to
replace than the tiles being bonded
directly to the structure again with
that bright red silicone RTV adhesive we
are now out of the communication
blackout and approaching 4 km/s or Mack
12 in velocity and are about 45 km in
altitude about four times the cruising
altitude of an airliner the Orbiter has
maintained that 40° angle of attack this
entire time being forced to hold an
angle of attack this large comes with
some control problems the Orbiter needs
to land precisely on a landing strip
from orbit managing its trajectory while
being stuck with its nose up would be
difficult especially for a glider with
no way to add energy once it's been bled
Away by drag if the space shuttle wanted
to lower its lift and lower its altitude
faster it could not lower its angle of
attack so the shuttle needed a special
way to adjust its trajectory to adjust
its landing area instead the Orbiter
decreased its lift by banking this split
the lift into vertical and horizontal
components reducing the lift keeping the
shuttle in the air and trading it for
lift that moved it sideways this is what
a typical re-entry flight profile looked
like this line is the angle of attack
keeping steady until Mach 12 and then
gradually reducing as it descends
through the thick lower atmosphere and
this is the bank angle as the Orbiter
crashes down from orbit it Banks wildly
from side to side the astronauts inside
who are already pointed 40° up are now
tilted on their sides up to 70° the
Orbiter is essentially doing the fastest
drift in history there are some quirks
to fly this high in the atmosphere at
Hypersonic speeds the bank angle
controls actually work in Reverse to
normal if we deflect the right elevant
down it should increase lift on the
right wing and cause that Wing to rise
banking the aircraft anticlockwise but
it doesn't when the elvon is deflected
downwards into the already compressed
Hypersonic air it causes drag to rise on
the outer Wing this causes the Orbiter
to turn its nose in that direction as
the nose turns in the direction of the
deflected elevon it Shields that wing
and causes a decrease in lift causing
the shuttle to Bank in that direction so
where a downwards deflecting elvon would
typically cause an increase in lift on
the wing here through a series of events
it causes a decrease in lift working in
Reverse of course this Bank angle causes
the Orbiter to drift off Target for its
landing and to correct it needs to bank
the other way the Orbiter has now slowed
down to Mach 3 and at this point the
flight crew deploy air data sensors to
to Aid in the Final Approach two probes
rotate from underneath the heat shield
on either side of the nose providing air
speed angle of attack and temperature
data to the flight computer at this
point the Orbiter is flying like a plane
but it's not a plane it's a glider and
the flight crew needed to carefully
manage the remaining energy to land
safely especially as the Orbiter was not
built like a traditional glider
balancing the need to survive re-entry
while maximizing lift efficiency was a
unique engineering challenge made more
difficult by Air Force funding causing
the design to skew closer to a plane
than a re-entry vehicle early concepts
of the shuttle Drew inspiration from the
X15 with much smaller Wings more than
enough to land the original smaller
Orbiter on a Runway the Air Force wanted
a larger payload capacity and they had
one more specific requirement that
required bigger Wings they wanted the
space shuttle to be able to take off
from Cape canaver complete its Mission
and land back at Cape Canaveral after a
single orbit essentially treating the
space shuttle like a military operation
to avoid Soviet attention fast and
Elusive this came with some issues a
single orbit took 90 minutes in which
time the Earth rotated below the
shuttle's orbit by 2,000 km so to return
to its launch location the Orbiter would
need to be capable of flying laterally
by at least 2,000 km this is called
cross range the original X15 inspired
design was capable of just 370 km of
cross range North American Rockwell
proposed this huge Blended body
deltawing Concept in 1970 which would
have given the Orbiter
2,800 km of cross range the fully
reusable concept with its crude booster
rocket and internal fuel tanks were not
to be but the large Delta Wings endured
these Delta Wings provided enough lift
in both hypersonic Supersonic and
subsonic flight regimes to provide the
cross range needed to reach the original
launch site after a single orbit despite
that the space shuttle was an unwieldy
aircraft and with no powered flight the
commander had one shot to land it safely
so they had to go through intensive
training in 1973 NASA created four
training aircraft by modifying four
Gulfstream Jets to fly like the space
shuttle in order to mimic the immense
drag the blunt by the design of of the
Space Shuttle would create the gulf
streams flew with their landing gear
down and their engines working in
reverse and flew with their flaps
deflected upwards to decrease lift with
flight characteristics like this the
space shuttle needed to carefully manage
its energy losing too much altitude far
from the runway would be far from ideal
the Pilot's aim Guided by beacons and
ground control for a tangential entry
into a circular approach path 5,800 m in
diameter just Off The Runway the moment
they intercept the circle the space
shuttle commences a deep spiraling turn
at this point the space shuttle is still
traveling at about 0.8 mock still very
fast and it's at this point the wings
are stressed the most hitting a higher
Max Dynamic pressure than at any point
during the re-entry process due to the
higher air pressure at this altitude and
The shuttle's Descent rate increases now
losing altitude rapidly with the
knowledge the Run Runway is within a
safe gliding distance descending to
about 3,000 m in altitude and slowing to
about 0.5 mock at this point the shuttle
enters a straight 20° down Glide
approach path much steeper than any
airliner approach path bleeding speed as
needed using the split Rudder speed
brake the rudder on the vertical tail
wasn't just used for controlling yaw by
deflecting left and right it could split
in two deflecting outwards to a maximum
of 62° on either side the gear is
lowered as late as possible and in the
final moments before touching down the
commander will increase the angle of
attack of the shuttle using the elevant
in order to slow its descent rate before
touching down at the moment of main gear
touchdown the speed brake is commanded
to fully open at this point the shuttle
is still traveling at 360 kmph close to
0.3 Mock and there is plenty of braking
left to do the runway at Cape Canaveral
is 4. 6 km long much longer than your
average runway with typical 3 km long
runways being able to deal with the
heaviest of jumbo Jets Landing as the
nose gear touches down the electr
hydraulic brakes in each of the four
main landing gear wheels are fully
engaged by application of the foot
pedals in the cockpit each brake
assembly had nine carbon lined burum
discs four rotors and five Staters which
were pressed together to provide braking
force on STS 49 Bruce melx Mission an
additional braking mechanism was
introduced hidden away underneath the
vertical tail speed brake the drag shoes
STS 49 was the maiden flight of both
Endeavor and the dra shoes an
explosively deployed parachute you can
even see the parachute door and Sabo
being flung from the back of the shuttle
on Landings it was designed to allow the
space shuttle to land on shorter 2,500 M
runways a contingency plan in the event
the space shuttle had to abort launch
and land on a runway on the other side
of the Atlantic for each and every
launch NASA sent staff to these
predetermined landing locations like
fairford RAF base in gler Shar England a
large team was needed to assist with the
final moments of each space shuttle
mission and these teams were not once
needed in the entire history of the
space shuttle program a giant fan was
even rolled out on the runway to help
disperse any toxic chemicals like the
hydren fuel away from from the shuttle
and the crew the mission is now over the
crew has disembarked and the space
shuttle will be refurbished and flown
back to Florida on the back of a 747 in
preparation for its next mission people
often say how incredible it is that
older Aerospace and Aviation projects
like this were designed with pen and
paper hand-drafted technical design was
an art form and a labor intensive art
form at that today computer AED design
makes things vastly easier like onshape
today's sponsor onshape is available to
try for free with the link in the
description whether your company wants
to evaluate a more modern cloud-based
CAD system or if you just need a design
program for home 3D printing projects on
shape is a fantastic option onshape is
built entirely on the cloud and because
of that onshape users have some unique
advantages for example engineers and
designers are able to work together in
on shape at the same time on the same
design across the globe ensuring there
is always a single source for your
designs a problem I had to contend with
in my job as a design engineer where
sales reps kept sending out old outdated
files to clients on shape also runs in a
browser which means you can use it on
virtually any device or operating system
even highly computa intensive
capabilities like finite element
analysis and rendering are done
completely in the cloud in on shape
making the design process faster and
easier than ever if you or your company
wants to test on shape engineers and
product designers can get the on shaped
professional plan for free for up to 6
months and the base free plan is
available for all for unlimited
non-commercial use you can sign up at
onshape dopro reengineering or by
clicking the link in the description or
on screen right
now